i don't know if you have a good answer
for this
but people love it when i ask this
question about books
um are there books
in um in your life that you've enjoyed
philosophical fiction technical that had
a big impact on you as an engineer or as
a human being
you know everything from science fiction
to a favorite textbook
is there three books that stand out that
you can think of
uh three books so i would uh you know
that impacted me
um i would say uh uh
this one is you probably know it well
um but and not generally well known
i i think in the u.s are kind of
internationally the master and margarita
it's uh one of actually my favorite
uh books um it is you know by
russian it's a novel by russian author
mikhail bulgakov
and it's just it's a great book it's one
of those books that you can like
reread your entire life and it's very
accessible you can read it as a kid
and like it's it you know it's the plot
is interesting it's you know the the
devil
you know visiting the soviet union and
yeah but
it it like you read it reread it uh at
different stages of your life
and you you you enjoy it for different
very different reasons and you keep
finding like deeper and deeper meaning
uh and you know it kind of affected you
know hadn't definitely had an like
imprint on me
mostly from the probably kind of the
cultural stylistic
uh aspect like it makes you one of those
books that you know is good and makes
you think but also
has like this really you know silly
quirky dark sense of you know humor
it captures the russians so that's more
than maybe perhaps many other books on
that like slight note
just out of curiosity one of the saddest
things is i've read that book
in english did you by chance read it in
english or in russian
uh in russian only in russian uh and i
actually that that is a question i had
uh uh kind of pose to myself every once
in a while like i wonder how well it
translates
if it translates at all and there's the
language aspect of it and then there's
the cultural aspect so i
and actually i'm not sure if you know
either of those would so work well
in english now i forget their names but
so when the covid lists a little bit i'm
traveling to paris
uh for for several reasons one it's just
i've never been to paris i want to go to
paris but there's a
the most famous translators of uh destio
tolstoy of
most of russian literature live there
there's a couple they're famous
uh a man and a woman and i'm gonna sort
of have a series of conversations with
them
and in preparation for that i'm starting
to read dusty asking russian so i'm
really embarrassed to say that i read
this everything i've read russian
literature of like
serious depth has been in english even
though
i can also read i mean obviously in
russian but
for some reason it seemed
uh in the optimization of life it seemed
the improper decision to do to read in
russian
like you know like i don't need to opt i
need to think in english not in russian
but now i'm changing my mind on that and
so the question of how well it
translates it's a really fundamental one
like it even with dostoyevsky
so from what i understand this day
asking translates easier
uh uh others don't as much obviously the
poetry doesn't translate as well
i'm also the the music uh
big fan of vladimir vosotsky he doesn't
obviously translate well people have
tried
but mastermind i don't know i don't know
about that one i just know it in english
you know it's fun
fun as hell in english so uh so but it's
a curious question and i want to study
it
rigorously from both the machine
learning aspect and also because i
want to do a couple of interviews in
russia
that i'm still unsure
of how to properly conduct an interview
across a language barrier it's a
fascinating question
that ultimately communicates to an
american audience there's a few
russian people that i think are truly
special human beings
and i feel
like i sometimes encounter this with
some incredible scientists and maybe you
encounter this
uh as well at some point in your life
that
it feels like because of the language
barrier their ideas are lost to history
it's a sad thing i think about like
chinese scientists or
even authors that like that
we don't in english-speaking world don't
get to appreciate
some like the depth of the culture
because it's lost in translation
and i feel like i would love to show
that to the world
like i'm i'm just some idiot but because
i have this
like at least some semblance of skill in
speaking russian
i feel like and i know how to record
stuff on a video camera
i feel like i want to catch like gregory
perlman who's a mathematician i'm not
sure if you're familiar with him
i want to talk to him like he's a
fascinating mind and to bring him to a
wider audience in english speaking
it'll be fascinating but that requires
to be rigorous about this question
of how well uh bulgakov translates
i mean i i know it's a it's a silly
concept but it's a fundamental one
because how do you translate and that's
that's the thing that uh google
translate is also facing
yeah uh as a as a more machine learning
problem but i
i wonder is a more bigger problem for ai
how do we capture the magic that's there
in the language
i i think that's a really interesting
really
challenging problem i if you do read it
mastering margarita in
uh english sorry in russian i'd be
curious
get your opinion and i think part of it
is language but part of it's just you
know centuries of culture
that you know the the cultures are
different so it's hard to
connect that but uh okay so that was my
first one right you had to add two more
um the second one i would probably pick
the science fiction by the straguski
brothers
uh you know it's up there with you know
isaac asimov and you know ray bradbury
uh and you know company uh the strugsky
brothers kind of appealed more to me i
think more it made more of an impression
on me
uh growing up um i
can you i apologize if i'm showing my
complete ignorance
i'm so weak on sci-fi which what are
they right oh
um roadside picnic um
[Music]
uh hard to be a god uh
uh beetle in an ant hill
uh monday starts on saturday like it's
not just science fiction it's also
like has very interesting you know
interpersonal and societal
questions and some of the language is
just
completely hilarious
that's the one that's right oh
interesting monday starts on saturday
so i need to read okay oh boy you put
that in the category of science fiction
uh that one is i mean this was more of a
silly
you know humorous uh work i mean there
is kind of
is about you know this this research
institute and like it's it's it
it it has deep parallels to like serious
research but
the the setting of course is that
they're working on you know magic
right and there's a lot of stuff so i i
i and that that's their style right
they go with the uh and you know other
books are very different right
you know hard to be a god right it's
about kind of this higher society being
injected into this primitive world and
how they operate there
like some of the very deep ethical you
know questions there
uh right and like they've got this full
spectrum some as you know more about
kind of more
uh adventure style but like i i enjoy
all of their books there's
probably a couple actually one i think
that they consider their most important
work
i think it's the snail on an on a on a
hill i don't know exactly how sure how
it translates i tried reading a couple
of times i still don't get it
but everything else i fully enjoyed uh
and like for one of my birthdays as a
kid i got like their entire collection
like occupied a giant shelf in my room
and then like over the holidays i just
like you know my parents couldn't drag
me out of the room and i read the whole
thing cover to cover
and it it uh i really enjoyed it
uh and that's one more i thought for the
third one i you know maybe a little bit
darker
um uh but you know comes to mind is
orwell's 1984. uh
and i you know you asked what made an
impression on me and the books that
people should read that one i think
falls in the category of
both you know definitely it's one of
those books that you read and
you just kind of you know put it down
and you stare in space for a while
yeah you know that that kind of work uh
i i think there's
you know lessons there people should not
ignore
and you know nowadays with like
everything that's happening in the world
i
i can't help it but you know have my
mind jump to some
you know parallels uh with what orwell
described and like this this whole
you know concept of double think and
ignoring
logic and you know holding completely
contradictory opinions in your mind and
not have that not bother you and you
know sticking to the party line
yeah uh at all costs like you know
there's there's something
there if anything 2020 has taught
me and i'm a huge fan of animal farm
which is a kind of friendly
as a friend of 1984 by orwell
it's kind of another thought experiment
of how our society
may go in directions that we wouldn't
like it to go
but if if anything that's been
[Music]
kind of heartbreaking to an optimist
about 2020
is that that society is kind of fragile
like we have this this is a special
little experiment we have going on
and not it's not unbreakable like
we should be careful to like preserve
whatever special thing we have going on
i mean i think 1984 in these books brave
new world
they they're helpful in thinking like
stuff can go wrong in non-obvious ways
and it's like it's up to us to preserve
it
and it's like it's a responsibility it's
been weighing heavy on me because like
for some reason like uh
more than my mom follows me on twitter
and i feel like
i have like now somehow a responsibility
to
um to this world and it
dawned on me that like me and millions
of others
are like the little ants that maintain
this little colony
right so we have a responsibility not to
be uh
i don't know what the right analogy is
but i'll put a flamethrower to the place
we want to not do that and there's
interesting complicated ways of doing
that as 1984 shows
it could be through bureaucracy it could
be through incompetence it could be
through misinformation
it could be through division and
toxicity
i'm a huge believer in like that love
will be
the somehow the solution so
uh loving robots yeah
i i think you're exactly right
unfortunately i think it's uh less of a
flame thrower
type of an extra i think it's more of a
in many cases can be more of a slow boil
and that's the danger
you